I was playing DnD this past weekend and it got me thinking about something really interesting here,
something that I Don't think most people think of in their day-to-day life.
As an exercise think of like the biggest franchises you can think of.
Pretty common ones come to mind, you think of like Marvel you think of like Iron Man and Superheroes
and all this stuff you think of like Disney and Pixar all these cartoons
Even think of Star Wars Star Wars is a huge HUGE franchise
all these movies, so much money has been made off this. Try making a Superman movie, or try making an Iron Man movie.
Try making a Star Wars movie you know what I mean
it's not gonna happen, and that's because of our current state of affairs and
Copyright control all these franchises have these giant fictional narrative universes that everyone knows all about
But there's one special one that you already know all about but is it special and it's different from all the rest,
and that is the Shared Fantasy universe. It's kind of like the open source of fiction right now
Everyone needs to take a moment to appreciate the shared fantasy universe it's because it has a deep-rooted
history in human culture. Dragons, elves, dwarves, all this stuff,
these concepts have been around in folklore and oral and written
Storytelling been passed down from generation to generation
And lead us to today, and lead us to incredible pieces of content that everyone knows and loves like Lord of the Rings,
Game of Thrones, Stranger Things.
When the kids open the books, the D&D books in stranger things and look up the Demogorgon
They look up the Mind Flayer. Yeah
Well, maybe that's not actually a Demogorgon, and maybe it's not actually a Mind Flayer
But the thing is they're using and they're tapping into this shared fantasy universe
to create new stories
this shared fantasy universe is the one that everyone gets to adapt and
explore and exploit for their own purposes
I really like the phrase "open source of fiction" because it does a really good job explaining its role and its significance
Everyone thinks of Game of Thrones as a franchise within itself
But really at its core, Game of Thrones is no more than Lord of the Rings fan fiction
I mean that is what happened
George R.R. Martin read Lord of the Rings and The Hobbit and was like "you know what? I love this universe
I'm gonna make my own version of it" and what's cool is is this all kind of comes back to Dungeons and Dragons because
Dungeons & Dragons is a storytelling tool set within this universe. When you watch Game of Thrones. You're like, "Oh well
I know how this universe operates". Well. There's obviously some magic. There's some dragons
There's some castles we get it and you know, we're not concerned about that stuff
We're just thinking about the characters within that story, but we live in a time of very intense copyright control
And there's a lot of people out there
Who if had the opportunity to somehow own part of this fantasy universe they would prevent other people from
Adapting it and using it as their own
Let's take a moment to talked about learning about education about learning how to do what you want to do in particular, right now
I'm going to talk about learning how to do filmmaking, but this video is sponsored by Skillshare
I actually do a lot of my learning
Online from other people who are gracious enough to share their skills and their knowledge with not only me
But anybody else who's looking it up. I know a lot of you are interested in filmmaking, or are filmmakers
You might find this part a little bit useful
There's actually a couple interesting
Video tutorials that I actually looked up on Skillshare before making this video, one was by a guy named Phil Abner
Which is actually how to make your web cam
Videos look good now
Now if you guys have followed us on Patreon and been part of the Hangouts, our
Our video quality on the hangouts isn't always the best, but now that I watched his tutorial
It's gonna be better. Back in the day when I was learning how to make videos how to make movies
I mean
I still am, you never stop learning. When I was really kind of cutting my teeth on all this stuff with Sam
We would spend a lot of time reading lessons and tutorials from other people online there, wasn't a whole lot of
actual nitty-gritty filmmaking teaching happening in our high school
We didn't really have books that dealt with that kind of stuff the best way for us to learn was to actually go online and
Learn from other people that were doing it who were gracious enough to share their skills and their knowledge with us. Back when I was younger
like
14, 15 years old
Sam and I were learning how to make videos and do visual effects, when we made our Star Wars fan film which is
On our Corridor channel. We didn't know how to make lightsabers
We needed to learn how to do lightsabers! Brian Weber at the time had made a great
Lightsaber tutorial effects on how to do them, from learning from his skills
We were able to do Lightsabers
Something like Skillshare is great for that kind of learning process if you want to learn from other people sharing your stuff online
Especially in a very clean curated presented way, Skillshare is perfect for that. There's a link in the description below
It's a free two months trial membership
They have a lot of lessons, actually over fifteen thousand lessons on the site covering a huge range of topics
If you want to check it out you can watch a lot of videos in two months
So you can find out if it's actually something that you find useful or not
(Car noises in background)
VRMMMM
(Niko imitating car noises)
That's the speed of my education that you hear revving up
Just imagine if somehow someone-just imagine if someone managed to copyright
Dragons like imagine imagine where that would put us today all the works and all the narratives that wouldn't exist
Because of that. I think it's probably a time to talk a little bit about copyright law because it's very important when you're dealing with
Fiction and works of art here you know copyright
Protects the creators of that work. When the U.S.
First had its copyright laws copyright only lasted for fourteen years, and now I admit. That's pretty short. That's pretty-
That's that's not even that long
Eventually it was extended to about 56 years
around 1909 and you know what? Honestly if you write a work of fiction or create a piece of art 56 years of
Protection that says that work is solely yours is probably enough because 56 years
That's more than a generation, so if you create something you know you are set for the rest of your life
but as we all know that's changed...
So there's this is thing called the "Mickey Mouse Curve" That's kind of interesting, and if you look at it
You can see that every single time the  character of Mickey Mouse is about to lose its copyright, copyright law
Extends by decades and obviously it's not a coincidence and that's because Disney created a character
And they wanted to own that character far longer than
What they were legally allowed to, So what did they do? they lobbied Congress they changed law
And if you would look at this curve you see it makes sense, because from a business standpoint
Mickey Mouse is an asset, a lot of people look at Disney movies and these stories and go oh well
They are beloved stories, these are
money-making machines, but if you imagine a world where copyright law somehow
Didn't extend, Disney would be a fraction of the size
They are today. First time Mickey Mouse was going to expire for copyright
They changed the law to say rather than 56 years copyright would last the author's lifetime plus 50 years
So I came up the cool cool character
I would gain the copyright for it for my entire lifetime, and then add 50 years on to that.
But that wasn't long enough because then around 1998 they had to change copyright law again
So rather than just being author's life plus 50 years. It's now the author's life plus 70
years or
120 years, whatever's greater. Now that was in 1998 and that was the last time U.S.
Copyright law was defined, which means that Mickey Mouse is going to expire again in
2023, five years from now. Are we going to see copyright law extend because of Disney's lobbying on Congress? Obviously
obviously, obviously! they've done it twice before they're gonna do it a third time. They are the largest media company. They're the largest
narrative company in the world, but the thing is is that
What this is doing though? It's turning these stories that people tell each other you know things that become
public works effectively and turning them into privatized properties
but if you look at how Disney got their start, Disney got their start by taking
shared fantasy stories, by using fairy tales, all their first stories like Snow White Peter Pan
Alice in Wonderland
Cinderella, Pinocchio
Basically in the public domain, and they used those they took them in and adapted them, and then they profited off it, and they founded
their empire on this. Now for them to start like that and then flip, and start actively working in
Copyright law so it's harder for other people to do that, feels it... it feels a little unfair
you know it feels a little false. Disney's been around for decades in a copyright law was the same today as it was when they
Started well a lot of the stories that they've adapted or helped create would be in the public domain
And allow other people to adapt them and work with them and cherish them in their own
Unique ways. Everything we know about copyright law today points
towards
Why?
to share the fantasy universe is one of the most crucial and important things we can hold on to right now
I personally believe in copyright. I think it's a good thing
I don't think this this is not about whether copyright is good or bad because it definitely protects our work
You know we have a YouTube channel
We create content obviously we should be the people to profit off it since we created it
But when does that end when should that end at what point do our stories become yours. That's the real question here
You know you hear a story from a friend, and you tell that to another friend
And you tell that to another friend and it changes and it adapts it stops becoming my story, starts becoming
your story. When I was playing D&D that last weekend
We had a great time. I thrust people into a brand new story, brand new setting, brand new characters, in D&D you're encountering monsters
But you're running around with magical swords. There's all this lore so somehow
For some reason they knew exactly how everything worked and that's because D&D is in this shared fantasy universe
I  came to that realization, like wait a second, the rules
And the stories and the creatures that are all within these books. We already all know this is something
That's that everyone owns. These these stories are ours. You know, they're not owned by anyone
You're working on something or you want to think of cool ideas, you know honestly picking up one of these books
It's not a bad place to start.